after waves of criticism for lack of
diversity in its membership and ethical
lapses the movie critics who choose the
golden globes film and tv awards says
it's changed its ways we changed our
rules bylaws added a new code of conduct
and restructured our governance
we also have 21 new members the largest
and most diverse in our 79 year old
history a los angeles times
investigation of the hollywood foreign
press association a tiny but influential
critics group showed it had not a single
black person among its less than 100
members and other minorities women and
lgbtq persons were underrepresented as
well they were slammed for their lack of
black members they were slammed for
their um token reform promises and their
questionable conduct and standards in
regards to
accepting money
or accepting trips or accepting gifts
for in exchange for a favorable vote
amid a fierce backlash the u.s
television network nbc dropped its
broadcast of the globes for 2022
actor tom cruise returned his three
trophies hollywood collectively shunned
the organization
the hfpa promised to add 13 new black
members but wound up with only six
including travell anderson a
well-regarded writer and critic who will
sit on the powerful credentials
committee they brought him in to help
diversify the membership of the hfpa and
travail is
a
binary trans
person so
that is very helpful but are the changes
enough
at least they're trying
but
they still they got a long way to go and
a broader question is hollywood as a
whole embracing diversity at last
hollywood is not starting to get it
hollywood has shenanigans
hollywood has shenanigans they start to
get it when they get called out best
television series snoop dogg announced
the nominees including kenneth bronx
autobiographical belfast we gonna do
this a different way king richard
starring will smith and jane campions
the power of the dog for best dramatic
picture
as well as licorice pizza
life matters
even more than love and steven
spielberg's adaptation of west side
story in the best comedy or musical
category
without a broadcaster for its awards
ceremony it's unclear how influential
these choices will be
on the all-important oscar awards that
follow in march
and whether the golden globes itself
will survive
rob reynolds al jazeera hollywood